زلزال التسريب يضرب الزمالك مجددا تهم
الفساد ما زالت تلاحق برشلونه الاسباني
بعد الافراج عنه كرنود يستعد للزواج من
صديقته هذه الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها عبر
قناه العربيه رياضه اسعدوا في متابعتكم
[موسيقى]
اشتعلت في الساعات الماضيه ازمه كبيره
داخل الوسط الرياضي في مصر والبطل اليوم
الزمالك فمع توديع الفريق لدوري ابطال
افريقيا وفقدان الامل في التتويج بلقب
الدوري المحلي بدات رحله تسريب العقود
للصفقات التي ابرمها الزمالك في الميركاتو
الماضي رواد السوشيال ميديا تودد تداول
اليوم صورا من عقد مصطفى الزناري المنظم
حديثا من طلائع الجيش ووفقا للعقد المسرب
فان اللاعب سيحصل خلال المواسم الخمس على
واحد واربعين مليون مصري تقريبا
نتحول الى برشلونه وتحديدا مع خبر دفع
اخوان لابورتا رئيس النادي الكاتلوني مبلغ
800 الف دولار تقريبا لابني رئيس لجنه
الحكام السابق في اسبانيا صحيفه
الكونفدنشن الاسبانيه كشفت في تقرير نشرته
اليوم ان مصلحه الضرائب المحليه توصلت الى
ان لابورتا دفع اموالا خلال مرحلته الاولى
كرئيس للنادي لخفير انريكل روميريو حين
كان وقتها مساعدا في المنتخب الاسباني
ووالده رئيسا للجنه الحكام برشلونه حتى
اللحظه ينفي وجود اي مخالفات ويؤكد ان
الاموال المدفوعه هي فقط لتقديم المشوره
للنادي بشان مسائل تحكيما لكن القضاء
الاسباني يشتبه بوجود فساد وتزوير في
سجلات ماليه
ننتقل الى البرازيلي داني الفيش الذي يمر
حاليا بفتره نفسيه رائعه ويتاقلم جيدا مع
الحياه داخل اسوار السجن فعلى عكس ما نشر
في الايام السابقه اكدت وكاله انباء
اسبانيه ان لاعب برشلونه السابق قام
بتاسيس بطوله كرويه بين السجناء وهو امر
دفع لزياده الطلب على الملابس الرياضيه
اربعه اضعاف ما هو معتاد عليه وعلى ذمه
المنشور فان الفيش قد خاض اول مباراه له
في قبل يومين وهو لا يعاني ابدا من حاله
احباط او انهيار او حتى اضراب عن الطعام
داخل السجن بسبب قرار زوجته الانفصال عنه
بسبب اتهامه باغتصاب فتاه في برشلونه
الختام مع جرينويد لاعب مانشستر يونايتد
الانجليزيه الذي يخطط حاليا للزواج من
صديقته الحامل هذا الصيف بعد اسقاط تهم
الاعتداء الجنسي الموجهه اليه مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي نشرت في الساعات
القليله الماضيه صورا للعب شياطين الحمر
وهو خارج من فندق وسط لندن من فئه خمس
نجوم مساء امس الاحد بجانب صديقته ياتي
ذلك ليؤكد استقرار الحياه الشخصيه بالنسبه
في الوقت الحالي ولكن مصيره مع الشياطين
الحمر يظل مجهوله بسبب قيام النادي
بالتحقيق معه بشكل داخلي رغم قيام الشرطه
باسقاط التهم الموجهه اليهم
[موسيقى]